the second amendment of the constitution
states that a well-regulated militia
being necessary for the security of a
free state
the right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be
infringed yes please gentlemen
we need all of your signatures gentlemen
a point of order what if
someone made a gun that could shoot say
50 people in 30 seconds
[Laughter]
congressman peele we have many orders of
business today
one of which is not judging your sense
of humor
pretentious as it may be
then one man would be able to walk into
a crowded area
and kill scores upon scores of people
before anyone
would have a chance to stop him
congressman peel where are you getting
these hair-brained ideas
how could you possibly know what
the future holds
because i am from the future
i know what this amendment will bring
and i cannot let any of you sign it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i did it did you see the
the muskets he had magnificent
and me the quill so i can draw them
before i forget
it